[Music]
all right here's a question once you buy
something do you
own it
like do you really own it like you can
do whatever you want with that thing
it sounds like a simple question but
there actually are a lot of limits to
what exactly you can do with what you
own so let's say you buy a car you get
the title it's yours you own it you can
do whatever go drive it somewhere
wherever you want to go but you also
can't drive over certain speeds in
certain places so that's a limit that we
understand we get it for safety reasons
or let's say you buy a printer you own
that photocopier that printer you can do
whatever you want with it put it in
whatever room you want put it on
whatever table you want to do start
printing stuff
but you know what happens if you try to
start photocopying money
it just doesn't let you
you can try well don't try but it'll
actually stop you you can't do that and
there are good reasons for that so there
are certain limits that we've actually
accepted for things that we own and so
one of those limits that's been talked
about quite a bit lately that's worth
shining a light on is right to repair
so if you own something and it breaks
should you be allowed to repair it fix
it honestly that should be a pretty easy
yes across the board there's no problem
with that and no one's going to stop you
if you try to do it there's no law
against it but it's almost impossible to
actually do it
let's talk about that
so right to repair
now i actually think it's a little bit
of a misleading name or a little
confusing just because you actually are
allowed to repair the thing you own
there's no law against that but it's the
companies that make the things that
we're often trying to repair that are
trying to stop you before you even get
that far so here is the the main crux of
the right to repair conversation right
now ready
you buy a thing right a piece of tech a
phone you own it you use it and then
part of it breaks let's say your screen
breaks that's pretty common
there are two versions of what you think
should happen at this point depending on
who you are there's the user side
there's the manufacturer's side so i'm
just going to start with the user side
because it should be the easiest to
understand
you should just be able to pop off the
broken screen
buy a new screen put it on
repair it and still keep using that
thing of course you should be able to
repair the item you own and there's a
million great reasons why repair saves
the user money of course so to stick
with the phone example if just the
screen is broken and the entire rest of
the phone is still functional then it's
way cheaper to replace the screen than
to buy a whole new phone of course but
also it saves the environment so instead
of creating unnecessary e-waste throwing
out a perfectly usable thing because one
broken part we can make a meaningful
change to this throwaway economy that so
many of us live in just keep using the
thing as long as it works and also the
fact is not everybody needs brand new
phones so if you someday want to upgrade
to a new phone somebody else can benefit
from that used phone with probably just
a few replaced parts that's way better
than throwing the whole thing out so the
fact is the more easily replaceable and
repairable parts that are in our gadgets
the better it is for the user
for the user and as you can probably
imagine that means that the
manufacturers the companies that are
making these things are on the complete
opposite side of that equation
they're gonna want control
so i'm going to use apple as the example
here right so they make this iphone
business 101 right once they sell you
this iphone sure you do own it but their
best interest is to retain as much
control over this iphone as they
possibly can because everything about
this transaction is better for them if
they have more control so you can pay
and own the iphone sure but if apple
controls the accessory market as much as
they can they can keep selling you
accessories and taking a cut of
everything made for iphone so they can
continue making money off of the thing
they sold you this is literally called
the mfi program made for iphone if apple
controls the services that run on the
iphone they can make their own work the
best and they can keep selling you even
more of those things and making even
more money off of that one iphone
purchase and if it breaks apple would
also like to be the ones to sell you the
repairs by keeping as much control over
that ecosystem as possible honestly in
apple's dream world there probably are
no independent repair shops at all right
you can't you can't have people getting
in and replacing parts in their precious
iphones you know they if someone does
the instructions wrong maybe they repair
something incorrectly and it doesn't
work or they get counterfeit parts and
they don't even know they're not using
real iphone parts or maybe they use a
weird third-party battery that has
problems later down the line like it's
too much
so
if apple has all the control here then
they eliminate all those possible
variables but you can't control
everything apple that would be a
monopoly actually so
and you can probably see where this is
going apple would like to offer you
a choice you can choose to become an
apple certified repair shop only the
apple certified shops have access to
apple's training official documentation
and the ability to buy official parts
straight from apple to do the best
possible repairs
but you have to pay a fee to apple to
become certified you have to log
everything and now there are lots of
limits actually to the types of repairs
you're even allowed to make it's to the
point where it would actually be a bad
business decision for a lot of these
independent shops that already exist to
become apple certified because it would
limit so much of what they were trying
to do
lewis rossman you might have heard of
him technician educator
guy with a youtube channel in new york
city he's made videos talking about this
listen to him describe all the potential
downsides of potentially joining that
program in one of his videos as i
mentioned in a follow-up video this
program is virtually useless because
they put a lot of barriers in place to
keep new people from being able to sign
up it seems like it's intentionally
designed to be difficult the prices for
screens were not great for the iphone 6
and 6s they're charging more for the
screen than a customer can purchase a
phone for and above all they don't do
anything besides batteries and screens
so charge port no batteries and screens
your microphone or earpiece doesn't work
nope just batteries and screens you have
a problem with your macbook i'm sorry we
only cover iphone batteries and screens
it is a virtually worthless program a
repair shops have to agree to
unannounced audits and inspections by
apple to determine if they're using
prohibited repair components which can
result in fines so i would be fined most
likely for being able to fix
motherboards in my premises by having
access to chips that apple doesn't want
me to have access to so you can retain
your data when i fix your board rather
than have it replaced by apple and
erased even if a shop leaves the program
apple can continue to inspect it for up
to five
years
imagine you have a job that requires
drug testing and you quit the job and
then they still try to enforce the drug
testing for five years yeah
yeah clearly there are countless
examples of apple
going the extra mile to prevent
repairs on the iphone lawsuits terrible
contracts something else lewis has
actually talked about in his videos is
apple has been known to make small
changes to an off-the-shelf part that
they put into one of their products and
then make a contract where that company
that makes that thing
cannot sell it to anyone other than
apple and that might seem crazy at first
it kind of is but when you think about
it from the perspective of a smaller
manufacturer apple descends upon your
campus and goes we'd like to order 20
million of this chip but you can't sell
to anyone else other than us
well with an order size that big
business sense says all right fine
they'll just do it and so they do now
i'm just using apple as an example here
because they're easy to understand but
there are a lot of other examples it's
not just apple
famously john deere yes the tractor
company has taken an extremely
anti-repair stance with their tractors
basically arguing farmers may own those
tractors but the software that runs on
those tractors is owned and copyrighted
by john deere so when something breaks
and the software locks the farmer out of
the tractor farmers have taken to
hacking their tractors and literally
digging into potentially pirated
software to get around those software
blocks and avoid dealing with the
company so they can repair it themselves
it's been a whole mess and even tesla
has notoriously very hard to get parts
and they just hate people messing with
the insides of their cars they
constantly lock out attempted salvaged
cars from the supercharger network and
from software updates they'll literally
blacklist certain vin numbers to prevent
them from getting any more software now
you could see how tesla might argue
that this is it's a safety thing it's
for safety reasons we don't want people
getting in those cars and making
modifications because they could hurt
themselves in an old car sure pop open
the hood change some oil but in a tesla
it's way more complex we don't want
somebody messing with the battery and
hurting themselves so that's that's an
argument they can make i actually
thought about this when simone yetch
made her truckload video where she
modified a brand new model 3 to a level
i've never seen anyone else go to she
turned it into a pickup truck and made
an incredible video about that process
that you should watch if you haven't
already okay so what was what was the
reaction
uh from tesla when you did all that like
did truckload get blacklisted we were
kind of building it with this like
fear hanging over our head that there
was going to be repercussions from tesla
that they were going to
stop me from getting software updates
which would be really bad um or that
they would prevent me from supercharging
which is kind of one of the like
penalties they can give you if you're
doing weird stuff right um fortunately
none of that happened and i think like
yeah the project got so much traction
that it would like look really bad for
them to go after me but it's also like i
i mean i i remember um scheduling a
service appointment because
i wasn't i had some software issues and
the service tech before i came in called
and was like hey
i know who you are and i know what
you've done to your car and i was like
and i was so freaked out that i actually
didn't go and it's kind of weird that
like
you're scared of a company punishing you
for doing something with their product
like you're you should kind of be
allowed to do whatever you want yeah i
guess the other side at least has one
good reason which is safety so you know
you had a lot of help and you had a team
that was really skilled around you but
most people aren't going to be able to
do really high quality modifications to
their tesla you know for sure i mean i i
think it's interesting because it's
like the reasoning around locking it
down so much is to keep people safe and
for people to not do dangerous
modifications i think truckless probably
like definitely in the realm of
dangerous modifications we did it as
safely as we could and like we have
every cross beam in the car and we had a
really really skilled team
but i get that they're like okay what if
we give people free hands like they can
kill themselves on this yeah and and you
see that they kind of use it as a reason
to
prevent even very small modifications of
being like oh people could do these
really dangerous things so we can't even
have them do these really basic things
and i think that's like it's all about
control and it's about
extending the time that you can earn
money on a product that you've sold
because if you control service and all
the upgrades and everything then you can
make sure that you can still earn money
on a car that you sold seven years ago
so i remember when i got into an
accident with a truck in apollo my tesla
model s and it was pretty rough like she
was clearly going to need a bunch of new
parts new doors etc you could tell that
just looking at it and i just remember
it got to the point where there was a
distinct choice that i had to make
between going to
literally any body shop in the area who
would do their best in a few weeks
or
getting it towed an extra hour to that
one tesla certified body shop
and they would have an extra long wait
for official parts but they would do
their best for a perfect repair
literally to tesla spec where if a tesla
engineer looked at it they couldn't tell
it's replaced parts
and i chose that one and that choice was
a combination of clearly i can't do it
myself it's far too complicated but also
you know the car was valuable enough to
me that i didn't really want to risk it
on a potentially subpar repair to save a
few weeks or a few dollars
but that leads me to my number one
overarching thought every time i think
about right to repair in tech
which is that
tech
is getting
very complicated
[Music]
so it is clear that right to repair
benefits
us the users you and me right we can see
that and we can also see that the
manufacturers are on the other side of
that equation
but something else i've noticed just in
the tech world
and kind of everything is tech but
something i've noticed is as tech gets
better especially lately it's getting
more and more well optimized and more
tightly integrated like parts are are
connected to each other more they talk
to each other faster all the tech is
getting better but it's getting more
well connected and more integrated and
so as that happens it's all the tech is
getting better
that's also making it less repairable at
the same time which makes sense right
because if things are more tightly
integrated and you're fusing chips onto
each other like that that's just harder
to disassemble and reassemble it's
harder to repair back in the golden age
of a lot of tech products maybe that's
the 80s or the 90s or the early 2000s
they were at that height of repair
ability like if somebody broke a
cassette tape player people literally
went in there with a screwdriver and
could take it apart and get a part and
replace it and put it back together and
you're good i actually literally managed
to pull exactly that off in retro tech
season one now today
if part of your gadget breaks say your
phone's glass cracks
look at your phone like most people
don't know actually how to replace that
themselves but it's technically
repairable so if you go to the right
place or the right people they can
remove the screen replace it and get it
working again with new parts so right
now right to repair is in this
little hotspot bubble in the middle
where with tech tech keeps getting
better and better and more and more well
integrated and at the same time it's
getting harder and harder to repair
what does that future look like it's
kind of a crossroads does the future of
tech trend to get so good that it's
trending towards impossible to repair
like look at these new m1 macs apple's
best max ever by far right i daily drive
the m1 macbook pro at this point they
also just announced this ridiculously
stunningly thin 11 millimeter m1 imac
and these machines are so good because
the m1 system on a chip is more tightly
integrated than ever like there is no
intel cpu that back in the day you could
pop out and upgrade there are no ram
sticks that you can just pop out on
upgrade there is no gpu that you can pop
out and replace everything is built into
this same chip
sharing memory and it works amazingly
well so does the future of even better
tech and faster tech mean a future of
almost impossible repairs like that was
my sticking point when i'm looking at
right to repair in tech like that
was hard to resolve in my mind
so i asked louis rossman about this this
is what he told me it's a good question
i think that there's two different
categories here so there's the first
category of repairs that are more
difficult because of technological
progress and the second category are
repairs that are more difficult because
the manufacturer just for lack of a
better way to put it just wants to be
so for instance like with laptops you
used to have a fluorescent backlit
screen you know like the fluorescent
lights that you have you'd see in
warehouses and then they use the led and
that'll instead of they used to have an
inverter board that was probably the
size of this remote control that was
sitting inside of every laptop it was
really easy to replace you unplug a wire
you plug it back in you can do this with
your with your hands you only need small
tools yeah then when the led backlit
screens came out which would use less
power they're brighter better color
it was a small chip on the board that
was soldered qfn and then it got even
smaller it was a ball girder ray trip
where the chip has nine little solder
balls or
25 solder balls under it and you need a
microscope and fancy equipment to solder
it on there
i'm not suggesting with right to repair
that we should go back to the stone age
and use devices with black and white
screens the problem is not with it being
smaller or harder to repair for me that
that's my responsibility to figure out
how to fix it as the technology gets
better and smaller and more integrated
what the problem is is it's not about
like the large board becoming a tiny
chip it's when i knock on texas
instruments door and say i you know i'd
like to buy a thousand of this chip and
they say we can't sell it to you the
manufacturer told us we're not allowed
to sell it to you
so
one of the big criticisms of right to
repair is you know i don't want to own a
phone that looks like gordon geckos and
wall street i don't if lewis had his way
everything would just have giant
phillips screws in it like something you
know where i hang on my wall and that's
not the case uh i
i would obviously prefer the ability to
replace the battery in my device without
having to use a heat gun and unglue it
that would you know my that's my
personal preference but i don't want
right to repair legislation to push my
personal preference for design on
consumers or on companies i just want it
to be if you're going to glue something
into the device whatever it is i'm
willing to jump through all those hoops
to to fix it but don't tell the company
that made this part they're not allowed
to sell it to me that is it's a good
take
i like that take ultimately
tech is going to continue to evolve and
to us of course it looks much more
complicated but also those who repair
tech will also continue to evolve and
continue to meet
that particular challenge so really what
we need at the end of the day is
well-written
well-considered legislation that does
not allow that anti-consumer
anti-competitive anti-repair behavior
that we've seen from so many companies
and that can preserve that ecosystem of
right to repair and then we can move
forward with a better future we deserve
the right to repair the things we own
simple as that and by the way the
environment deserves that too like that
we only get one planet earth and last
time i checked a lot of these companies
are painting themselves as a pretty
green like apple and tesla
last time i checked every john deere
tractor is pretty green so we deserve
that chance so that's been it thanks for
watching hope you enjoyed and big shout
out to louis rossman and simon yetch for
taking time to chat they're very busy
people and also we're working on an
episode of the waveform podcast in video
form that expands on this a lot that
talks to more people and has sort of a
all-encompassing right to repair video
so i'll have all the links below
including the link to the waveform
channel and let me know what you think
in the comments what do you think about
this movement
again that's been it talk to you guys
the next one
[Music]
peace if they it would have been
devastating if they turned me off as
superchargers like then you can't
what are you gonna do like
find some refrigerator outlet on a gas
station and plug it in especially
because
side note her range is completely busted
since i modified her because it changed
the aerodynamics so much and i also
swapped out the tires for custom tires
that are really uh and wheels that are
really heavy
um so i mean her range is like 60 of
what it used to be so she needs a lot of
charge you still daily drive it though
yeah no i mean she's she's she's all i
got